I
hero you guys had what's called an idiot
crazy a loser you must break society
status quo one person with the belief
overrides thousands of people with just
in 10 and the difference between a
champion and someone who's forgotten is
that champion shows up I'm up here I'm
up here because I failed I continue to
fail I love failure
they grow the individual will to become
something you must get comfortable with
fear and failure they must be your best
friend you're the only one that moves
that needle of life and just like you go
to the gym and you lift your muscles
right you have to exhaustion to grow on
perishable use it or lose it your
confidence must be the same way it must
be tested every single day safety
comfort zones are dead zones because
your true potential will never be
matched guys what is that about the
willpower the belief of confidence
to tell you something everybody gets one
chance to do something great
most people never take the chance either
because they're too scared but it will
recognize it once it's on their shoes
this is your big chance that you
shouldn't let it go by
your life guys is not about making money
it's not about having the titles it's
not about having the hot trophy wife
your life is about a moment to come it's
inevitable we cannot stop it from coming
right now we have the most valuable
asset on earth on our side time but it's
money now and to make that first step
towards greatness is the hardest step
we show up and be your best and that
opportunity doesn't come that often
we all had the ability to do anything
you